okay uh let me ask you do we have a
phone to make a call or no i got a guy
uh my sergeant from the army just texted
me from 20
from 1998 which by the way
did he did he ever find out
how long has he lived in nashville
that's crazy if he's listening he
actually went to that club with me but i
don't
i have a story of his but i'm not going
to tell her maybe he'll tell it but
maybe he's not going to tell it it's a
pretty crazy story but yeah here let me
let me get felix if you're ready i'm
calling you tell me text me and tell me
yes i'll call you if you're ready
freaking wonderful how many times did
this guy scream at you
uh who this guy we're calling oh by the
way let me just tell you like do you
know what his size is
felix let me let's see if he's on or
listening to this before i call this guy
felix is
oh my gosh felix i got like a billion
stories did you did you say he was like
your corporate or who was there an
officer i was i was a a specialist he
was a sergeant and he was uh
the sergeant of supply all right let's
see if we're gonna get a hold of this
guy
let's
i'm doing pretty good how about yourself
patrick i am doing good man so what's
the word what are you thinking about
what's going on here with afghanistan
tell us tell the audience who you are
tell our relationship
and give us your idea about what's going
on in afghanistan
you know so patrick you know i i saw
your video and of course like you know
rest of the world i'm sure they're you
know they look at those those videos are
in shock i mean i've had a lot of family
and friends and even people i served
with and just kind of give a little bit
of my background that you were saying
i'm 20 years you know army retired uh i
have five combat tours three of them
being in afghanistan or actually three
being in iraq and one in afghanistan so
i spent over four years of my life you
know in the middle east uh between 2003
and 2011.
um our relationship you know i know me
and patrick we served together back at
fort campbell
um you know back in the day and um you
know i remember you telling me stories
about life you know in iran growing up
and so you know as far as you know i
didn't get that perspective of living in
the middle east until of course i spent
you know a good chunk of my life there
and um you know what i see is just
tragic you know it's unfortunate and
like i think i put on your post you know
the fact that
um you know when i hopped on a plane i
remember the colonel briefing us you
know and they're in the hangar at fort
campbell and it was like how many guys
been to iraq and you know of course i
raised my hand it was my second tour at
the time i did three tours total and he
was like a lot of you think you might
know what you're stepping into but like
when you go to afghanistan it's a
completely different world and i'm like
what's he talking about
and of course he said it's kind of like
the time you know time has stood still
so
um until i was in charge of uh you know
afghanistan detail where i was in charge
of basically 10 people we worked at
entry control points and so
you know i i dealt with them the every
day i i fed them i've trained them and
it was just just blew me away just how
far they were behind to the modern world
so felix can you can you can you paint a
picture for the rest of us
iraq afghanistan so
modernized education
you know level of lifestyle what it was
like maybe maybe paint a picture for
some that don't know
okay so i mean i guess the best way i
can put it is like you know my parents
originally grew up in mexico right and
so when when as an american i'd go to
mexico i would always be in shock of
like it's like a kind of a second world
country you know which is not as
developed as america the technology
infrastructure
and when i went to when i went to iraq
you know i kind of identified it as kind
of like i would say not say like mexico
but as far as just infrastructure and
the people and education you know but
maybe just a little bit behind but when
you go to afghanistan i mean patrick
it's literally like you're going 3 000
years back in time wow i mean i know
there's do people will say well they see
the buildings they see all that but i'm
talking about the everyday individual
the people the farmers the countrymen
the people that are out there they're
just literally behind
the modern world i mean even when i went
to iraq i remember i was in charge of uh
interpreters so i remember they used to
tell me in iraq now think about this
perspective
that they were shut off to the rest of
the world they weren't able to have uh
uh only certain channels
right so saddam hussein controlled the
information flow that came in there so
their perspective of americans was
completely different until we were there
and they saw how friendly we were how
they were there to help them when they
were given that or they don't even
they're shut off to the rest of the
world they don't know what the rest of
the world looks like if that makes any
sense
no of course now felix when you when you
when you so you being there and amongst
all the other soldiers you're around
officers you're around sar majors you're
around sergeant first class first
sergeants captains colonels generals
you're on all these guys
behind closed doors when it's just
sitting around shooting you know you're
just having a conversation together what
was the position of most of the soldiers
i'm talking more the leadership not
necessarily
those who are not leading was there is
their position amongst each other why
the hell are we here in the first place
this should have never happened what the
hell are we doing it's a waste of money
you know we could be back it's costing
so many people's lives or was it more
from the standpoint of we got to do our
part to help
it's so necessary for us to be here if
we weren't here it'd be such a [ __ ] show
it'd be much worse what was the language
of leaders not victims and complainers
who don't want to be there who can't
wait to come back i'm talking those who
are aspirational leaders at one they
want to move up in the ranks in the
military what was the conversation
behind closed doors i mean i mean
honestly i i really feel that even as
leaders even for for some of the even
the soldiers is like you know you you
you know you might join the military for
different reasons and you know respect
for whatever they join for but once you
go there you mean you're a human patrick
i mean you should know this right you
know you're like wow i i can't believe
people live like this or they or they
have lives like this and so you know i
think overall
for a lot of the sentiment is what
basically you're looking for
is that we realize that this is a real
problem
and the fact that you know um if we
don't change and i think i send you a
text saying that we need to be there for
100 years and i know of course that's
going to cost the taxpayers a lot of
money i know there's people that have to
go there and serve but it's not just
america's problem it's the world's
problem
got it so felix your position is that we
should have never pulled out of this
last week or you know 10 days ago we
shouldn't have pulled out
i mean from a humanitarian i mean i mean
i mean i'm sure as people look at in awe
right i mean of course i don't
um
you know i don't write the checkbook and
i know that that's a cost to american
taxpayers and and i know there's people
that actually have to go there and serve
it and potentially risk their lives but
i think from a humanitarian effort i
mean you're looking at it that these are
people and individuals like anyone else
until you're there and see it and
realize like how good you have it here
in america and and you should know that
you know you're telling me the stories
of you know when you used to uh get
bombed there in iran but it it it is
just completely opposite out there and
it's like you know when you see the kids
and they're just like you give them
i have a picture and i wish i had it and
this is in iraq so this is back in 2003
when i was convoy back from uh
from being there and i remember stopping
in our convoy like literally like like
five in the morning and some kid ran up
to me and i'm literally like giving and
he was just like can i get like he was
like water water and i gave him a bottle
of water and you thought i would have
given this guy you know this this kid
you know ten thousand dollars i mean
it's just a different mindset until you
have that experience
you know i think it's very moving and
and people i think overall even the
world i mean even as americans i think
we're very empathetic to to people's
causes and of course we want to help a
lot of people and i know it's tough
someone's got to step up but i don't
think it's just america's responsibility
it's the world's responsibility hey
felix oh sorry buddy go ahead this is
tom this is tom cena i have a quick
question for you with your perspective
fighting the taliban when you uh were
deployed there a what potential do they
have to actually change do you buy this
that they could be a different version
of the taliban right now and b
what would realistically happen to any
americans or contractors that worked for
america as interpreter or anything else
what would happen to them if they were
left behind and not rescued
um i'll be honest i mean they the hatred
you know
from from them is that's all they know
that's all they've been raised on when i
said they have to be there for a hundred
years you have to change a mindset and
that doesn't happen i mean think about i
was there in 2008 to you know uh to 2009
for 13 months and
you know it's just completely different
mindset you have to go in there
and change you know it's a generational
thing and when i say 100 years these
people just think different well i was i
was mainly wondering will the taliban
kill any americans or their contractors
left behind are their lives in danger if
we don't get them out and do you believe
the taliban can change from my
perspective i would say yes
i would say yes they would be because
they were grown to to to hate americans
and they don't know any better i mean
they they think we're there to take the
resources and
and change their way of life and their
ideology and and if they feel that way i
mean they don't they don't think
anything about us you know i mean it's
just they're they're their language of
how they speak
you know
follow-up question for you here's a
follow-up question for you let's let's
get a little bit more logical so all
this stuff you said i'm fully with you i
totally under i i remember when i got on
the flight to lufthansa flight when i
left iran july 15th of 89 and we crossed
the border and the
flight attendant says if we can
officially serve alcohol everybody
started cheering and clapping because
they finally fell free you did not feel
free until it left the iranian border
that's when we finally felt free so i
understand that part of it but the other
part of it some people may say
well
we got 800 military bases in 70 plus
countries china's got one military base
by suez canal you know
djibouti is their base that they have in
djibouti and we got all these other
bases we're spending all this money
we're spending all this taxpayers money
should we go out there and try to solve
every country's problems or should we
let them handle it themselves
i mean to be honest with you if it's if
it's you think it might not be our
problem but if they're harboring you
know terrorism and they they view us as
the enemy i mean just
i mean whether you want to believe it or
not in our eyes we never would have
believed 9 11 would have ever happened
you know and
prior to 9 11 that was unconceivable
patrick but now it's it's it's
conceivable if that makes any sense of
course so
so what i think in my perspective is
that whether we like it or not
you know and whether what it costs if we
if we ignore that then what it could
potentially harbor will make 911 be even
worse i mean think about what happened
with colvin i mean god forbid if they
were
had the intelligence or had the
technology to do to to harbor
you know biological warfare if anything
the world has thought that that that's
that's that's the real threat you know
what i'm saying how do you how strongly
do you feel about our military today
like today how strong do you feel about
the policies we're making today with the
military like do you feel safer today
than you did maybe 10 years ago 20 years
ago tell me about how you're feeling
right now with being safer today than it
was 10 or 20 years ago
you know patrick
that's a great question
i'll share this with you uh my son is
currently in the army my oldest son is
my father he's he's he's serving at four
campbell the place that we serve
together so
um you know i have friends that are
still in and the perspective you know
that i get
is that you know um the military is very
dynamic just like it should be it's
constantly changing sometimes changing
for the good sometimes changing for the
bad and just the direction even when i
got out you know i got out in 2013 when
i retired after 20 years is that you
know that we're trying to be
and this is you know quote me if i'm
crazy if you say that i think we're just
trying to be too
you know overly sensitive and
unfortunately the military is is is not
a business it's not a public
organization i think that's how they try
to they're trying to run it today to be
everyone politically correct
um it's it's tough i mean i mean i know
our leaders have a tough job you know
whether that you know i don't want to be
uh
you know uh critical of a
commander-in-chief you know the best you
can do is say hey you know when i was in
the army you know we're going to support
him 100 you know that's that's our job
especially being a leader
and you know um
it's
it's honestly i think if we don't
if we don't um
if we don't if we ignore that problem it
might not affect us now
but it might affect us 10 years from now
so you think another 911 is eminent and
it just the chances of it increased
yeah absolutely increasing i don't know
percentage-wise but i mean yeah i mean
uh i mean look at they they were waiting
they were waiting in the wings for for
years for us to pull out
well felix can i can i uh first of all
what i'm curious about is when are you
running for mayor senate congress
governor when you're running for some
kind of political you know it's a funny
story when i moved to texas when i moved
to texas when i visited you in
california you were hinting about moving
to texas yeah i don't know what they put
in the water here i'll be honest i
absolutely love it here in texas
um i mean just to think about it i
literally live like probably 15 miles
where tesla's building new factories
where are you you're in austin right if
i remember
yeah so if i move for me if i if i run
for for political office i think i'll
start off as mayor and then work my way
up well do your thing buddy i mean i i
feel like listen you know shit's gonna
come out people are going to know how
hard you party by the way i don't you
can't you can't hide that stuff because
you know when
can i tell the people a couple stories
about you is that okay patrick
absolutely honestly i'll be honest i
tell stories to you might to my kids and
you know 99 of them are positive
we went to spring break together but
we'll show that for another for now
which one is that is that is that lavila
is that panama city yeah i i told him i
told him
when you were doing that dance contest
and then all of a sudden yeah you jumped
the body contest i remember that i
forgot about that one until you brought
it up but we drove and you remember when
we got trophies in your offices
what's crazy about this by the way that
club was a legit club club lavila was
the whole mtv rap all that stuff they
were doing it but we drove this is how
bad the situation was we had a truck
that only
would fit three people me bradford and
felix would sit in the front in the back
for nine hours four people were sleeping
wow we would drive obviously this stuff
is illegal we don't recommend it kids
please do not do this one of these days
the romney thing that he had to do you
know that story's going to come back for
us hell of a bar man
there is a guy you want to party with
it's felix felix is the guy you want to
party with felix was a guy he would have
25 beers the night before and he would
go out run everybody the next day at
five o'clock in the morning that's
freaking felix
he would run five-minute miles
six-minute miles just piss everybody off
do all the push-ups score perfect pt
score in and out now we'd have 12 beers
together by the way felix and i
we watched cocktails together felix how
many times have you watched
the other day dude we botched that thing
probably like a hundred times we watch
cocktails non-stop
and uh there's a certain we watched what
was it cocktails what was the patrick
swayze movie you had roadhouse we
watched roadhouse and there's a few
movies we would watch
and patrick speaking of movies uh i i
want to kind of give you uh if you ever
want uh i know you're doing the your uh
your mafia with uh yeah
your mafia movie uh i've got some good
perspective of uh of goodfellas that no
one's ever done before if you ever want
to sit down and do it i'm good with the
autopsy of goodfellas i'm your guy we
will we will i am definitely looking
forward to that one of these days you
got to come out to florida we'll do
something together but felix good to
have you on brother give everybody my
best
you said florida you moved to florida
i'm in florida right i'm in fort
lauderdale right now i don't live in
texas anymore i'm in fort lauderdale
i've been here for
uh what is it now seven months six
months seven months we've been down here
florida well i i definitely know anita
said that she wanted to do with the
valuetainment tour so we'll definitely
uh we'll come out that way to florida
sometime and get the tour and get a
chance to catch up so thank you for uh
having me on the show uh i wish my best
for you and your family and hopefully
we'll have a chance to catch up soon
okay i'll show you buddy take care
bye-bye bye-bye what a freaking guy man
this guy he was a pool hustler sick
player like when i took maybe he was the
best player on the entire base out of 30
000 soldiers but we'd go two place
here's what this guy would do he's five
six hundred twenty-five pounds felix
we'd go to a uh uh billiard hall a pool
hall right he would start and he would
start you know
talking trash to everybody and here's
what he would do he would say say
something say something
like challenge him challenge him
i'm on the other side he says say
something you see that i got that guy's
my friend
go ahead buddy and he would fight
everybody and then i'm like felix yeah
you're just trying to hang out man
say something watch what's gonna happen
we're gonna destroy you and we have to
let me ask you when when uh it's always
awkward man like do do former veterans
do you like when people like thank you
for your service when they're like thank
you for your service
is it weirder you know but i tell you
when somebody does that it's also
you want to be uh appreciated you know
you want somebody to value
uh this is 20 years you're talking about
the one of the stories you didn't talk
about he was in an in a humvee when they
went over and i i i don't know what it
was felix drove there was like an
explosion and he was in there he saw
this stuff so
he messes with you a little bit when you
get out of it right now he's been away
from it for nearly a decade but when you
get out of it at first
it's mentally and emotionally
challenging so yeah but it does uh it's
always great when people say that so if
you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast click
over here take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]